let's do this alright skip is gone in
high school I wasn't much of a
celebrator I just you know two to the
chest one to the sky and you know just
go to the sideline to everyone they did
a good job but my little brother kind of
told me like gotta loosen up but you
gotta have fun with the guy okay you'll
see that my god Thaddeus was wide open
inside our tight end patties ma he made
sure to let me know that he was open on
that play and I didn't throw it to a my
because that would have been his first
touchdown of the year and so he made
sure that he let me know that for the
rest of the year and he ended up he had
three touchdowns in the last two games
so I got him back but he made sure to
let me know that and then you see you
see my guys dancing in the end zone they
love they love celebrating my
celebration start to get a little a
little chaotic I start like flexing I
started like hitting bebop I started
doing crazy things and then I looked
back at and I'm like what
I just got destroyed and then zone I
just got destroyed then no one was open
I thought I'd be able to run and if you
look at I was like two two yards and
then zone already and I got hit and I
just thought like geez man
yeah so so I I thought I'd get up and
show everyone that I'm okay and I don't
know what how I came to mind but if you
look at it that's like probably the only
other thing that I do it just flex
that's that's it is this you know this
and then just just the play that's
that's all I can vividly remember
throughout the season
then I went to the equipment managers
that Wednesday to see if they could do
it for me and as soon as I I said that
their eyes kind of lit up and they were
fired up about it you know to me not
really it doesn't feel that weird but
but to like everybody around me I think
it's super weird to like my mom and dad
and my friends from high school because
they just know me as no Joe or Joey and
you know all these people are know
making videos and commenting on my know
my posts and so I think it's more weird
for them than it is for me it's also
good to hear the crowd you know and in
the background I mean when when when
you're in the moment like that you can't
really hear too much of that you don't
hear too much of the crowd in-game but
just being able to look back at a play
like that and listen to the crowd the
excitement of the crowd I mean it's it's
awesome he told me you know before
before we went out just hit national
championship which is crazy to think
about now you know give me the ball I'll
go get it
you know just throw it and I was go get
it on I mean I I had no hesitation I
just held the safety in the middle you
know I'm knowing where I was gonna go
with the ball threw the ball outside he
made a catch and I mean that was a big
play and potentially we could have came
back to the game if we if we got the
onside kick after that play but I mean
unfortunately unfortunately we didn't
but you know yeah it was exciting that
was really exciting
and the Alabama in eight years
I love playing on the road no before the
game riding warmups no we I would I
purposely threw right in front of the
student section for the game on this on
this particular day and they started
this little chant behind me had had
something to do with you know the f-word
and you know my name and my coach came
up to me and he said they must not know
what happens to people that knew that
they'd say those things about you
and so that was to start that was the
start of that day even against teams
that that weren't ranked that we played
before our big games you know I mean
those were all big games because these
teams BB seems had nothing to lose and
and I mean any any opportunity that
teams like that you know get to play a
team and showcase you know where they
stand as far as talent against a team
like Alabama I mean they're gonna
they're gonna use that opportunity I
think we're all kind of in a life
changing moment right now in this
quarantine now I'm about to get another
one on Thursday a team picking me to be
mostly their quarterback for the next
ten or fifteen years and I hear my name
called out I don't know what emotions
are gonna come out I'm not happy at lb I
don't know how emotional I'll get but
all I know is and the feeling of all of
that is is gonna be able to change my
family's life around so that's that's
something that I'll be forever proud of